[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis schenken abend an diesem
samstag und den sport hat norbert
lehmann fest mit tennis oder fußball
bundesliga eine schöne und andere von
mir die ukraine bringt die russischen
truppen in bedrängnis
erfolgreiche gegenoffensive die ukraine
hat strategisch wichtige städte zurück
moskau räumt rückzug einh
[Musik]
stadt queen jetzt king charles der
dritte wird zum britischen könig
ausgerufen
attacke und abgrenzung von der regierung
auf dem bundesparteitag in hannover
ringt die cdu um ein klares profil
die ukraine hat offenbar einen ihrer
bislang größten militärischen erfolge
erzielt das russische militär gab heute
den rückzug einiger truppen im osten des
landes bekannt die besatzer riefen zudem
alle menschen zur flucht auf in den
bislang von ihnen kontrollierten orten
im gebiet raacke die ukraine hat nach
eigenen angaben mehr als 1000
quadratkilometer zurückerobert
und zwar sowohl im süden des landes bei
chassan als auch im nordosten in der
nähe von haag elfte rang die ukraine
wohl besonders weit auf russisch
besetztes gebiet vor und kontrollieren
angeblich wieder q1 keine strategisch
wichtige stadt thomas reichert es könnte
ein kleiner schnitt seien die ukraine
rückt im osten und süden der front weit
vor erobert unter dem beifall der
bewohner zahlreiche ortschaften ich habe
gestern nacht verkündete präsident
selensky geländegewinne zu diesem
zeitpunkt haben die streitkräfte der
ukraine mehr als 30 siedlungen in der
region karte für freiheit und unter ihre
kontrolle gebracht
heute nachmittag die nachricht dass
koblenz von ukrainischen truppen
eingenommen worden sei ein strategisch
wichtiger auch dem osten ebenso wichtig
neben koblenz soll die ukraine nun auch
ist um zurückerobert haben ein weiterer
eisenbahnknoten der ukrainische erfolg
wäre ein schwerer schlag für russlands
nachschub offenbar werden russische
truppen gerade von dort abgezogen das
räumt wortreich sogar russlands
verteidigungsministerium ein
und die erklärten ziele der sonde
operation zur befreiung des dollars zu
erreichen wurde beschlossen die in den
gebieten von ballack lava und easy um
stationierten russischen truppen und zu
gruppieren und die bemühungen in
richtung denn jetzt zu verstärken zu
diesem zweck wurde innerhalb von drei
tagen eine operation durchgeführt um die
organisierte verlegung der truppen
gruppe ist jung auf das gebiet der
volksrepublik dann jetzt zu verhindern
zur gleichen zeit kommt am rande von
kiew heute vormittag überraschungsbesuch
aus deutschland außenministerin baerbock
will sich erklären lassen wie sie hier
russische minenräumen baerbock zeigt
sich schockiert dass selbst in
kinderspielzeug in privaten wohnung
minen gefunden wurden sind die
offensichtlich nichts anderes zum ziel
hatten als unschuldige menschen selbst
kinder zu töten wer aber glaubt putin
spekuliere darauf dass europa der
ukraine hilfe überdrüssig werde diese
rechnung dürfe nicht aufgehen mit den
aktuellen nachrichten von der front
hofft die ukraine die unterstützung auch
aus deutschland weiter aufrecht zu
erhalten
schauen wir noch einmal genauer an der
region in der ost ukraine ungefähr auf
halbem weg zwischen hp und dem
strategisch wichtigen koblenz liegt das
dorf backofen aus dem sich die russische
armee jetzt zurückgezogen hat vieles ist
zerstört unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf war dort
das dorf grad kurve drei tage nach der
befreiung wir begleiten eine einheit der
ukrainischen polizei beim ersten einsatz
der nicht ungefährlich ist denn überall
haben die russischen soldaten minen
hinterlassen
jetzt kommen mir die techniker die alles
and mine wir sprechen mit den menschen
wir leisten auch psychologische hilfe
und humanitäre unterstützung
ein halbes jahr war das dorf von der
russischen armee besetzt fast alles
haben die soldaten zerstört vom
kirchturm aus sollen sie auf die
menschen geschossen haben patronen
liegen überall verstreut nur wenige
dorfbewohner sind geblieben
so ungefähr 40 menschen sind noch
geblieben die die kein geld haben und
nirgendwohin konnten
ein team der polizei hat ermittlungen
begonnen denn nach hinweisen von
dorfbewohnern soll es folterungen und
erschießungen gegeben haben am rande der
straße bergen die polizisten zwei tote
an zwei weiteren orten soll es gräber
geben alles genau zu dokumentieren ist
den beamten wichtig ein polizist führt
uns in einen hof überall spuren die die
russischen soldaten hinterlassen haben
die hier offenkundig ihre lager
aufgeschlagen hatten ein dorf endlich
befreit doch es wird noch lange dauern
bis die bewohner zurückkehren können
gehen wir direkt zu katrin eigendorf in
die ukraine kathrin wie ist denn das
vorrücken der ukrainischen truppen
einzuordnen
also das was wir vor allem heute hier
erlebt haben nämlich die fast eroberung
von kopien und ihr so einen bedeutenden
knotenpunkt für die nachschub lieferung
der russischen armee das ist schon eine
der bedeutendsten wänden in diesem krieg
seitdem die
ukrainische armee es geschafft hat die
russen aus der umgebung von kiew zu
vertreiben es ist noch umso bedeutender
als gerade jetzt die ukraine darum ringt
westliche waffen zu bekommen und nach
sechs monaten krieg es ja auch in europa
viele diskussionen darum gibt ob das
wirklich noch sinnvoll ist diesen krieg
in dieser form weiterzuführen
die ukraine haben hier im osten gezeigt
dass sie durchaus geländegewinne
erzielen können dass sie in der lage
sind den russen etwas entgegenzusetzen
und was man hier hört aus den befreiten
orten ist gibt schon auch ein
erstaunliches bild ab anscheinend ist es
so dass russische soldaten sich
teilweise zivilisten kleidung
übergezogen haben uns kampflos
aufgegeben haben und geflohen sind also
das bild das sich hier ergibt das wirft
auch viele fragen auf zur stärke und zur
moral der russischen truppen das heißt
ja das was wir jetzt hier in der ukraine
erleben könnte vielleicht eine deutliche
wende in diesem krieg seien allerdings
wir hier in kharkiv was er die
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine ist
erleben gerade im moment immer wieder
angriffe durch artillerie gerade vor
einer stunde hat es hier wieder zu
einschläge gegeben das heißt die
situation hier spitzt sich deutlich zu
dankeschön parteien eigentlich
legen wir jetzt ins vereinigte
königreich
70 jahre lang war thronfolger
heute wurde teils auch ganz offiziell in
einer prunkvollen zeremonie als neuer
könig ausgerufen
geboren wird er am 14 november 1948
charles der älteste sohn der queen
1981 heiratete er daher öffentlich eine
märchenhochzeit
tatsächlich aber eine unglückliche ehe
er ende noch 15 jahren stürzt das
königshaus in eine krise
2005 heiratete charles camilla seit
jahrzehnten engagiert er sich für den
umweltschutz und nun ist der ewige
thronfolger könig kinch als der dritte
aus london
die briten werden sich an eine neue
formulierungen gewöhnen müssen in ihrer
nationalhymne heißt es nach 70 jahren
queen nun god save the king
die ära des neuen monarchen ist
offiziell ausgerufen
charles phillips george ist mit dem tod
unserer regentin alleiniger herrscher
und unser rechtmäßige könig charles der
dritte
zuvor war die proklamation im st james
palast vollzogen worden dazu wurde ein
so genannter thronbesteigung rat
einberufen ehemalige premier
kirchenvertreter hohe beamte
regierungsmitglieder gehören dazu eine
rein formaler akt mit dem tod seiner
mutter war charles automatisch könig
geworden zum ersten mal wurde die
zeremonie live übertragen die blu-ray
ich bin mir des großen erbes und der
pflichten und der schweren verantwortung
des monarchen die mir nun übertragen
wurde so tiefst bewusst
auf den straßen warten sie und wollen
ihn sind den neuen könig
[Applaus]
historischer moment für dieses land und
das fühlt sich so gut an dabei
in große fußstapfen aber hat in seiner
ansprache gestern schon gesagt er will
für die monarchie leben so wie es unsere
klienten hat
manches protokollarische detail wirkt in
der heutigen zeit vielleicht etwas
antiquiert aber so sind die alten
bräuche des britischen königshauses
das ganze baut auf uralten traditionen
auf das haben wir heute gesehen es ist
ein seltsames überbleibsel aus der
vergangenheit punkt und pantomime
bei allem jubel für king charles die
königliche familie und das volk trauern
weiter gemeinsam um elisabeth die zweite
am frühen abend zeigen sich die sinne
des königs vor schluss winzer
jetzt also auch offiziell neuer könig
andreas stamm in london was kommt auf
den bereichen zu
sehr kurzfristig erst mal die letzten
vorbereitungen der entscheidung was die
beisetzung seiner mutter der queen
angeht und wie heute etwa der tag ist
festgelegt worden dass wird montag der
19 september sein und könig charles hat
ihn auch gleich zum feiertag erklärt
dann wird er zu einer reise in die
anderen landesteile außerhalb englands
aufbrechen in dieser woche nordirland
wales und schottland um sich eben auch
dort als neuer könig vorzustellen und ja
er wird er da programmiert einen tag
später ganz in der tradition
langfristig allerdings da sind mammut
aufgaben kann er einen des band sein so
ähnlich wie seine mutter gerade in
nordirland und schottland wo es ja noch
den drexhage spannungen immer noch
bestrebungen gibt das königreich zu
verlassen und ja selbst hier vor dem
buckingham-palast ja ob er seine briten
die sich jetzt hier versammeln bei der
stange halten kann denn die popularität
des königshaus hat abgenommen nur noch
60 prozent wollen die monarchie 20
prozent lehnen sie ab das ist deutlich
gefallen und das ja in dem zeitalter der
über populären queen ich glaube dass
wenn er das hinkriegt das wäre ein
großer triumph aber das ist eben eine
mammut aufgabe gerade bei den jüngeren
da steht es mittlerweile 50 50 danke
nach london andreas stamm
ja wie geht es weiter im vereinigten
königreich auch in unserer app halten
wir sie darüber auf dem laufenden
da gibt es auch viele hintergründe
beispielsweise eine fotogalerie über die
vielen hobbys des neuen königs
die cdu hat sich auf ihrem
bundesparteitag in hannover für die
einführung eines verpflichtenden dienst
jahres für junge menschen nach der
schulzeit ausgesprochen als soziales
oder als ökologisches jahr oder bei der
bundeswehr vor allem aber gab sich die
partei eine neue grundwerte karte zu
besuch beim treffen csu-chef söder mehr
von ines trams
der beifall für den csu-chef auf einem
cdu parteitag war schon mal größer
markus söder sticheleien aus dem
bundestagswahlkampf dürften vielen hier
noch in erinnerung sein er selber gibt
sich selbstkritisch demonstration traute
einigkeit 20 21 war nicht unser bestes
jahr sind viele fehler gemacht worden
von allen natürlich auch von mir aber
wir haben daraus gelernt
die zusammenarbeit in fraktion und
partei ganz besonders mit eurem
vorsitzenden lieber flüssig läuft
exzellent eine grundwerte kater
diskutieren die delegierten basis für
ein neues grundsatzprogramm der partei
hitzig streiten sie obmann
gleichberechtigung von frauen und
männern als ziel festschreiben will oder
gleichstellung was wir nicht brauchen
ist ein staat der sich anmaßt in
lebensentscheidungen erwachsener frauen
und männer korrigierend einzugreifen und
für klein stellung gar noch für
tatsächliche gleichstellung in allen
lebensbereichen zu sorgen wenn wir
wahlfreiheit wirklich ausmalen das ist
grundvoraussetzung
gleichstellung und deshalb überhaupt
nichts mit gleichmacherei zu tun das
wort gleichstellung bleibt im text auch
am abend zuvor die frage wie progressiv
will die cdu seien nach engagierter
debatte stimmte sie für eine frauenquote
zunächst befristet auf fünf jahre diesen
kleinen schritt zu tun diesen kleinen
schritt zu tun den mut sollten wir doch
wohl haben auch bringt der parteitag
sich dazu durch ein verpflichtendes
dienst jahr für junge leute zu empfehlen
ein parteitag auf dem sich die cdu
zumeist mit sich selbst beschäftigte
in die schweiz da ist jetzt klar wo das
endlager für atommüll gebaut werden soll
nämlich nur wenige kilometer hinter der
landesgrenze zu baden württemberg nahe
der gemeinde hund hängen tief in der
erde sollen dort ab 20 50 atomabfälle
eingelagert werden in der schweiz sind
aktuell vier atomkraftwerke am netz
der reformprozess in der katholischen
kirche darf nicht scheitern mahnt der
vorsitzende der deutschen bischöfe
bätzing homosexualität ämter für frauen
drei tage lang hat der synodale weg also
die vollversammlung aus bischöfen und
laien in frankfurt um veränderungen und
der druck ist groß denn für märz
kommenden jahres ist die
abschlusskonferenz geplant in den kinder
über blockaden und fortschritte
die anti stress bälle die es gab waren
nötig denn es war ein auf und ab der
gefühle für viele mitglieder des
synodalen wegs erst verzweiflung und
tränen als ein wichtiges papier über
eine veränderte sexualmoral der
katholischen kirche an der notwendigen
zwei drittel mehrheit der bischöfe
scheiterte dann jubel der erleichterung
dass über den umgang mit homosexualität
und die priesterweihe von frauen neu
nachgedacht werden soll
es ist frauen papier so durchgekommen
ist war mein persönliches
herzensanliegen ich weiß nicht wie viel
jahren und ich bin der meinung dass wir
einige kleine sehr katholischen schritte
nach vorne gemacht haben aber wir haben
leider heute auch gesehen dass es sehr
wenige leute in dieser versammlung gibt
die wirklich den mut haben macht
strukturen zu verändern
der vorsitzende der bischofskonferenz
riecht immer wieder seine amtskollegen
zusammen um auch möglichst viele
konservative zu überzeugen und das
schlimmste zu verhindern ein scheitern
des gesamten reformvorhaben
sein signal heute nicht aufgeben auch
wenn noch lange keine entscheidung
endgültig ist das wissen alle die hier
versammelt sind und das wissen alle mit
denen ich unterwegs bin dass das ein
langer weg ist aber das ist ein votum
der kirche in deutschland bischöfe und
laien gibt mit dem wir nach rom gehen
können das ist ein starkes zeichen im
nächsten frühjahr will die synode
sammlung ein letztes mal zusammenkommen
außerdem soll ein neuer ausschuss
entstehen in dem bischöfe und laien
dauerhaft gemeinsam entscheidungen
treffen
zu den us open norbert da gab es ja
heute nacht wieder so ein tennis krimi
ein geradezu episches halbfinale 4
stunden und 18 minuten carlos alcaraz
aus spanien bezwang publikumsliebling
francis tv aus den usa knapp in fünf
sätzen und trifft im finale auf den
norweger kaspar loeb die neue nummer
eins in new york die wird auch die neue
nummer eins der welt
[Applaus]
tennis match beim so starken us
verlierer frances die auf ich habe alles
gegeben gegen carlos was ich hatte ich
habe alles gegeben diesen turnieren wenn
ballwechsel mit stehenden ovationen
enden bei spaniens lawn tennis da oben
in einem packenden gar dramatischen
halbfinale ein teleskop wird zum
tollhaus
tennis der zukunft vor den augen der
früheren first lady michelle obama
45 stunden
wieder einmal gewinnt der 19-jährige
alcaraz nach fünf sätzen der spanier den
viele als die neuen nadal sehen steht
als spanisches ausdauer wunder nun in
seinem ersten grand slam finale gegner
dort der norweger caspary den kampf um
die nummer eins der welt
in der fußball bundesliga haben die
bayern zum dritten mal hintereinander
unentschieden gespielt aber zunächst
einmal die tabellenführung zurückerobert
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des
sechsten spieltags
münchen gegen stuttgart 2 zu 2
hoffenheim bezwingt mainz klar mit 4 2 1
frankfurt verliert gegen wolfsburg mit 0
21 härter und leverkusen trennen sich
unentschieden 2 2 und leipzig mit dem
neuen trainer marco rose gewinnt gegen
dortmund souverän mit 13 0 das
abendspiel schalke gegen bochum bereits
gestern unterlag bremen den augsburgern
mit 0 1 die tabelle die bayern also
erstmal spitzenreiter hoffenheim springt
auf platz zwei vor dem sc freiburg der
morgen wieder die tabellenführung
zurückerobern kann dortmund rutscht von
24 union fünfter die berliner die
könnten aber morgen sogar auf platz eins
klettern mein sechster die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit leipzig auf
rang zehn und am tabellenende leverkusen
schalke und die noch punktlosen bochumer
ja das endspiel der kellerkinder schalke
gegen bochum ausführlich bei uns zu
sehen aktuellen sportstudio um 23.30 zu
gast oliver ruhnert der geschäftsführer
von union berlin beim großen preis in
die zahl von italien in monza startet
schale claire morgen von der pole
position
der ferrari pilot gewann das qualifying
vor weltmeister max fürst ab und carlos
sainz ebenfalls ferrari sebastian vettel
abgeschlagen siebzehnter mit schumacher
geht sogar morgen als letzter auf platz
20 ins rennen für ferrari fahren die
italiener jubeln vettel und schumacher
hinten ich schweige danken
noch zum wetter nach einem kühlen
unbeständigen tag heute beruhigt sich
das wetter morgen von westen her wenn er
zugleich von christa haben das heute
schon mal können sie an diesem abend um
23.15 sehen mit anne gellinek bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend der blick aus dem zdf
gebäude heute zeigt ein prachtexemplar
eines schauers hier der regen fällt
lokal eng begrenzt hier in diesen
schlieren und außen herum bleibt es
trocken und genau dann sprechen wir von
einem schauer im gegensatz zu regen der
viel großflächiger feld und auch aktuell
sind viele schauer und gewitter noch
unterwegs im nordosten fallen die in der
nacht langsam in sich zusammen der
flächige regen im süden der zieht aber
weiter nach osten von westen her wird es
etwas trockener hier ist vor allem in
nordrhein-westfalen stellenweise ja
heute einiges zusammengekommen in der
feuchten luft bildet sich dann auch
nebel dazu sinken die temperaturen am
alpenrand auf 10 an der mildensee auf 16
grad morgen ist es schon etwas milder
als heute verbreitet 20 bis 23 grad aber
von der ostsee bis nach bayern bleibt es
noch kühler 17 bis 20 grad denn vor
allem hier sind die schauerartigen
regenfällen vereinzelt mit gewittern
noch zu finden und im tagesverlauf
ziehen die sich aber etwas nach osten
zurück ansonsten nur einzelne schauer
oft trüb anfangs später von westen aber
auflockerungen denn die neue woche
startet mit viel sonne bis dienstag
erreichen wir im südwesten aber 28 grad
das war dann aber der höhepunkt und es
wird ab mittwoch schon wieder kühler
tschüss